العديد من الارقام والاحصائيات سجلت في
لقاء فرنسا وبولندا ولقاء انجلترا
والسنغال اللاعب الفرنسي اوليف جو اصبح
الهداف التاريخي لمنتخب بلاده بعد تسجيل
هدفه الثاني والخمسين متجاوزا النجمه
الفرنسي السابق تري اورينت المدرب الفرنسي
دادي حقق انتصاره الثاني عشر كمدرب للديوك
الفرنسيه منذ كاس العالم عام
2014 ايضا حارس المنتخب الفرنسي
لعب مباراته الدوليه رقم
واثنتين واربعين وتعادل مع ليليان ترامب
بعدد المباريات اما المنتخب الانجليزي بعد
فوزه على السنغال حافظ على سجله المميز
امام المنتخبات الافريقيه بكاس العالم
باربعه انتصارات وثلاثه
مدرب انجليزي يصل ربع كاس العالم مرتين
بعد مواطنه الفرنسي عام
و1970 وايضا بوبي روبسون عام
1986 و 1990